You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.|||你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路而已。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去荒郊野岭了！或者你也可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到你的海景房。距离水边仅数步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Competition is everywhere. From classrooms to boardrooms, from sports to social media, we're constantly sizing ourselves up against other people and being sized up in return.
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Competition is everywhere. From classrooms to boardrooms, from sports to social media, we're constantly sizing ourselves up against other people and being sized up in return.|||希尔顿特惠活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得你期望的住宿体验。当你追求实惠而非惊喜时。住哪里很关键。希尔顿，伴您好梦。竞争无处不在。从教室到董事会，从体育运动到社交媒体，我们不断地将自己与他人进行比较，同时也反过来被他人评判。
Sometimes that might drive us to work harder and perform better, other times it could leave us anxious, discouraged, or unwilling even to enter the race. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies how competition shapes our behavior. What drives some people to be extremely competitive in their work, in relationships, and in life. Which situations bring out the competitiveness in us? How much does competition correlate with success? Is it necessary to have a strong competitive drive if you want to achieve big things? Do men and women differ in how they respond to competitive settings? I suspect many of us think it's possible to be too competitive. So what are the potential negative effects of competition? And what's the best way to deal with overly competitive?
Sometimes that might drive us to work harder and perform better, other times it could leave us anxious, discouraged, or unwilling even to enter the race. Today we'g going to talk to a psychologist who studies how competition shapes our behavior. What drives some people to be extremely competitive in their work, in relationships, and in life. Which situations bring out the competitiveness in us? How much does competition correlate with success? Is it necessary to have a strong competitive drive if you want to achieve big things? Do men and women differ in how they respond to competitive settings? I suspect many of us think it's possible to be too competitive. So what are the potential negative effects of competition? And what's the best way to deal with overly competitive?|||有时这可能会促使我们更加努力工作、表现得更好，而有时它却会让我们感到焦虑、沮丧，甚至不愿意加入竞争。今天，我们将采访一位心理学家，他研究竞争是如何塑造我们的行为的。是什么驱使某些人在工作中、人际关系中以及生活中极具好胜心？哪些情境会激发我们的好胜心？竞争与成功之间的关联有多大？要想成就大事，是否必须具备强烈的竞争驱动力？男女在应对竞争环境时的反应有何不同？我猜我们许多人都认为，好胜心太强是可能的。那么竞争的潜在负面影响是什么呢？应对过度好胜的最好方法是什么？
people in your life. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Stephen Garcia, a professor in the Graduate School of Management at the University of California Davis. Dr. Garcia's research focuses on the psychology of competition, especially the situational factors that amplify or diminish competitive behavior. His work has been published in leading journals across the behavioral sciences and covered by mainstream media outlets, including the Wall Street Journal, the New York Times, and the Washington Post. He's also the lead editor of the Oxford Handbook of the Psychology of
people in your life. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Stephen Garcia, a professor in the Graduate School of Management at the University of California Davis. Dr. Garcia's research focuses on the psychology of competition, especially the situational factors that amplify or diminish competitive behavior. His work has been published in leading journals across the behavioral sciences and covered by mainstream media outlets, including the Wall Street Journal, the New York Times, and the Washington Post. He's also the lead editor of the Oxford Handbook of the Psychology of|||生活中的人。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是加州大学戴维斯分校管理研究生院教授斯蒂芬·加西亚（Stephen Garcia）博士。加西亚博士的研究重点是竞争心理学，尤其是那些放大或削减竞争行为的情境因素。他的研究成果发表在行为科学领域的各大顶尖期刊上，并被《华尔街日报》、《纽约时报》和《华盛顿邮报》等主流媒体报道。他还是《牛津心理学手册：|||
Competition. Dr. Garcia, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for inviting me. So how do you define competition in your research? So in my own research, I use, the lens of social comparison theory to understand competitive behavior. And basically, whenever we anticipate that someone is going to outperform us or if we observe someone outperforming us, we're going to behave competitively to minimize the gap in performance. Why are some people more competitive than others? What are some of the characteristics of their personalities? And is there a competitive personality type? Yes, so there's individual difference variables that capture competitive personalities.
Competition. Dr. Garcia, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for inviting me. So how do you define competition in your research? So in my own research, I use, the lens of social comparison theory to understand competitive behavior. And basically, whenever we anticipate that someone is going to outperform us or if we observe someone outperforming us, we're going to behave competitively to minimize the gap in performance. Why are some people more competitive than others? What are some of the characteristics of their personalities? And is there a competitive personality type? Yes, so there's individual difference variables that capture competitive personalities.|||竞争》的主编。加西亚博士，非常感谢您今天能来。谢谢您的邀请。那么，您在研究中是如何定义竞争的呢？在我的研究中，我使用社会比较理论的视角来理解竞争行为。基本上，每当我们预料到有人会表现得比我们好，或者当我们观察到有人表现得比我们好时，我们就会表现出竞争行为，以缩小表现上的差距。为什么有些人比其他人更有好胜心？他们性格的一些特征是什么？是否存在一种竞争型人格？是的，有一些个体差异变量可以捕捉到竞争型人格。
And basically, people who are high in trait competitiveness will behave competitively. But there are other independent or individual differences that will also predict competitive behavior, such as the concern for social comparison. If one is concerned how they compare relative to others, they will also dispositionally be more inclined to behave competitively. You study the situations that are likely to bring out anyone's competitive side or conversely diminish their desire to compete. What are some of those factors? So one of the factors that we've looked at is the number of competitors in the competition.
And basically, people who are high in trait competitiveness will behave competitively. But there are other independent or individual differences that will also predict competitive behavior, such as the concern for social comparison. If one is concerned how they compare relative to others, they will also dispositionally be more inclined to behave competitively. You study the situations that are likely to bring out anyon's competitive side or conversely diminish their desire to compete. What are some of those factors? So one of the factors that we've looked at is the number of competitors in the competition.|||基本上，特质竞争性高的人会有竞争行为。但还有其他独立或个体差异也能预测竞争行为，例如对社会比较的关注。如果一个人关心自己与他人相比如何，他们在性格上也更倾向于表现出竞争行为。你研究了可能激发任何人的好胜心，或者相反会减弱他们竞争欲望的情境。其中一些因素是什么？我们研究的因素之一就是竞争中竞争对手的数量。
So maybe conventional wisdom would suggest that having more competitors means that people are going to be even more competitive. But what we find is that more competitors can sometimes diminish the motivation to compete. So for example, in one of our studies, we would ask people to complete an easy quiz as fast as they could, and we would time that quiz the amount of time it took. And so what we found was those people, those research participants that were told they were competing in a pool of 10 competitors, finished the quiz significantly faster than those who were told they were competing in a pool of 100 competitors. And so, again, the idea is when you have many competitors, you're just not as motivated to compete as when you have only a few.
So maybe conventional wisdom would suggest that having more competitors means that people are going to be even more competitive. But what we find is that more competitors can sometimes diminish the motivation to compete. So for example, in one of our studies, we would ask people to complete an easy quiz as fast as they could, and we would time that quiz the amount of time it took. And so what we found was those people, those research participants that were told they were competing in a pool of 10 competitors, finished the quiz significantly faster than those who were told they were competing in a pool of 100 competitors. And so, again, the idea is when you have many competitors, you're just not as motivated to compete as when you have only a few.|||传统观念可能会认为，竞争对手越多，意味着人们的好胜心就会越强。但我们发现，竞争对手增多有时反而会减弱竞争的动机。例如，在我们的其中一项研究中，我们要求人们尽快完成一个简单的测验，并记录测验所花费的时间。我们发现，那些被告知自己与 10 名竞争对手同台竞技的研究参与者，完成测验的速度明显快于那些被告知与 100 名竞争对手竞争的人。因此，这里的观点再次印证了：当你有许多竞争对手时，你的竞争动机不如只有少数几个竞争对手时那么强烈。
And I should mention, too, that we also told them that the top 10% in each pool would win a prize. And so the chances of winning were the same in both conditions. What about a situation like the Boston Marathon, the New York City Marathon? I mean, there are lots of people there are competing. Does that make you more or less competitive if you're one of the runners? So definitely in terms of those marathons, obviously some of them are more competitive marathons to even qualify for and pretty permitted to run. But all else being equal, what we're suggesting is that when people are,
And I should mention, too, that we also told them that the top 10% in each pool would win a prize. And so the chances of winning were the same in both conditions. What about a situation like the Boston Marathon, the New York City Marathon? I mean, there are lots of people there are competing. Does that make you more or less competitive if you're one of the runners? So definitely in terms of those marathons, obviously some of them are more competitive marathons to even qualify for and pretty permitted to run. But all else being equal, what we're suggesting is that when people are,|||我还应该提到的是，我们还告诉他们，每个组别中前 10% 的人将赢得奖品。因此，在这两种情况下，获胜的机会是相同的。像波士顿马拉松、纽约马拉松这样的情况呢？我的意思是，那里有很多人在竞争。如果你是其中一名跑步者，这会让你更有好胜心还是更少好胜心？就这些马拉松而言，很明显，其中一些马拉松甚至要获得参赛资格都竞争激烈，且对参赛有名额限制。但在其他条件相同的情况下，我们想说的是，当人们，
running with people of similar ability as their own, wherever you are in that ability, if they're like you in ability, then the more people you're running with, the less competitive motivation you would feel as opposed to only a few. And part of this goes back to social comparison theory. So when we think about competing competition in a small group, it's easy for us to keep tabs on how we compare to, let's say, eight other competitors. in the small competition. But if we have 100 competitors in that competition, it's much more difficult, impossible to keep tabs
running with people of similar ability as their own, wherever you are in that ability, if they're like you in ability, then the more people you're running with, the less competitive motivation you would feel as opposed to only a few. And part of this goes back to social comparison theory. So when we think about competing competition in a small group, it's easy for us to keep tabs on how we compare to, let's say, eight other competitors. in the small competition. But if we have 100 competitors in that competition, it's much more difficult, impossible to keep tabs|||与自己能力相仿的人一起跑步时，无论你的能力处于什么水平，如果他们的能力与你相似，那么与你一起跑步的人越多，你感受到的竞争动机就会越少，这与只有少数人一起跑时形成鲜明对比。部分原因可以追溯到社会比较理论。因此，当我们考虑在小群体中进行竞争时，我们很容易掌握自己与（比方说）其他 8 个竞争对手的比较情况。在这个小规模竞争中。但是，如果我们在该竞争中有 100 个竞争对手，那就困难得多，甚至不可能去掌握
in terms of how we stack relative to every other single competitor. And so because we can't keep tabs anymore in those larger competitions, the motivation to compete goes down. Again, we sort of look at this through the lens of social comparison theory. That is social comparison is the engine behind the competitive motivation in this particular case. Do people generally feel more competitive when they're pitted against friends or strangers? Does that make a difference? Yeah. So interestingly, there's been some established research by Abraham Tessor showing that
in terms of how we stack relative to every other single competitor. And so because we can't keep tabs anymore in those larger competitions, the motivation to compete goes down. Again, we sort of look at this through the lens of social comparison theory. That is social comparison is the engine behind the competitive motivation in this particular case. Do people generally feel more competitive when they're pitted against friends or strangers? Does that make a difference? Yeah. So interestingly, there's been some established research by Abraham Tessor showing that|||我们相对于其他每一个竞争对手的排名情况。正因为我们在那些规模更大的竞争中无法再掌握这些情况，竞争的动机便会下降。同样，我们通过社会比较理论的视角来看待这个问题。也就是说，在这种特定情况下，社会比较是竞争动机背后的引擎。当人们与朋友或陌生人竞争时，通常会觉得好胜心更强吗？这有什么区别吗？是的。有趣的是，亚伯拉罕·特塞尔（Abraham Tessor）的一些既定研究表明，
when others outperform us, if we're close to them or have a close relationship with them, it can sometimes be a more competitive experience than if it's a stranger. So for example, I mean, Abraham Tessor has looked at this in many ways. And what he found is that you can actually see that close relationships can sometimes be more competitive than relationships between strangers. And I think back in the day, there was a song by Morrissey and the title of his song was, We hate it when our friends become successful. And I think part of that kind of captures the competitiveness that can happen between those we know versus those that we do not know. What about competing against yourself?
when others outperform us, if we're close to them or have a close relationship with them, it can sometimes be a more competitive experience than if it's a stranger. For example, I mean, Abraham Tessor has looked at this in many ways. And what he found is that you can actually see that close relationships can sometimes be more competitive than relationships between strangers. And I think back in the day, there was a song by Morrissey and the title of his song was, We hate it when our friends become successful. And I think part of that kind of captures the competitiveness that can happen between those we know versus those that we do not know. What about competing against yourself?|||当别人表现得比我们好时，如果我们与他们关系亲密或有着密切的关系，有时这种体验会比面对陌生人时更具竞争性。例如，我的意思是，亚伯拉罕·特塞尔从多个方面研究过这个问题。他发现，你实际上会看到，亲密关系有时甚至比陌生人之间的关系更具竞争性。我想起过去有一首莫里西（Morrissey）的歌，歌名叫《我们讨厌朋友变得成功》（We hate it when our friends become successful）。我认为这在某种程度上捕捉到了在我们认识的人和不认识的人之间可能发生的竞争性。与自己竞争呢？
Is that enough of an incentive to drive people to great heights? I mean, speaking of a marathon, say you just want to outdo your personal best in running, or do we do better when we're competing against others? That's a good question. I would say that you may be able to meet the goal through either case, whether you're trying to do your personal best versus trying to best another competitor. And I would also add that it's probably the case that the healthier competition for many would be trying to just improve their own score as opposed to having an interpersonal in trying to be. beat someone else. And part of this insight would come from what we know about mindset. So Carol Dweck studied a mindsets. And basically there's two different mindsets. One is a growth mindset where you just look at your own behavior and you're trying to grow. And so you might espouse competition
Is that enough of an incentive to drive people to great heights? I mean, speaking of a marathon, say you just want to outdo your personal best in running, or do we do better when we're competing against others? That's a good question. I would say that you may be able to meet the goal through either case, whether you're trying to do your personal best versus trying to best another competitor. And I would also add that it's probably the case that the healthier competition for many would be trying to just improve their own score as opposed to having an interpersonal in trying to be. beat someone else. And part of this insight would come from what we know about mindset. So Carol Dweck studied a mindsets. And basically there's two different mindsets. One is a growth mindset where you just look at your own behavior and you're trying to grow. And so you might espouse competition|||这足以成为激励人们达到人生巅峰的动力吗？我的意思是，说到马拉松，假设你只是想打破自己在跑步方面的个人最佳成绩，还是我们在与他人竞争时表现得更好？这是一个好问题。我想说的是，无论是努力打破个人最佳成绩，还是努力战胜另一个竞争对手，你都可能通过这两种情况中的任何一种来实现目标。我还想补充的是，对许多人来说，更健康的竞争可能是仅仅努力提高自己的分数，而不是进行人际间的攀比去试图击败别人。这种见解的部分来源是我们对思维模式的了解。卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）研究过思维模式。基本上有两种不同的思维模式。一种是成长型思维模式，即你只看自己的行为并试图成长。因此，你可能会拥抱竞争，
as a way for you to grow in some particular task. Whereas a fixed mindset is more of the sensibility that however you perform is it's very fixed and you can't really change it. And a lot of times those people with fixed mindsets are more inclined to socially compare themselves to others. And there are downstream consequences of that in terms of psychological well-being, for example. I mean, people with growth mindsets are better off psychologically than those who have fixed mindsets. And again, I think if you were to read Carol Dweck's book, she offers many colorful examples, sobering examples of how the fixed mindset, which again, I would say is more connected to social comparison, you vis-a-vis someone else could actually go down a bad path.
as a way for you to grow in some particular task. Whereas a fixed mindset is more of the sensibility that however you perform is it's very fixed and you can't really change it. And a lot of times those people with fixed mindsets are more inclined to socially compare themselves to others. And there are downstream consequences of that in terms of psychological well-being, for example. I mean, people with growth mindsets are better off psychologically than those who have fixed mindsets. And again, I think if you were to read Carol Dweck's book, she offers many colorful examples, sobering examples of how the fixed mindset, which again, I would say is more connected to social comparison, you vis-a-vis someone else could actually go down a bad path.|||将其作为在特定任务中成长的一种方式。而固定型思维模式则更倾向于认为：无论你表现如何，这一切都是固定不变的，你无法真正改变它。很多时候，那些拥有固定型思维模式的人更倾向于将自己与他人进行社会比较。这会对心理健康等方面产生下游影响。我的意思是，拥有成长型思维模式的人在心理上比拥有固定型思维模式的人过得更好。再说一次，我想如果你读过卡罗尔·德韦克的书，她会提供许多生动的例子、令人清醒的例子，说明固定型思维模式——再次我要说，它与社会比较联系更紧密——你与其他人相比，实际上可能会走上一条糟糕的道路。
Do people tend to be competitive in all aspects of their lives, or is it more common, say, for somebody to, you know, you're an athlete, so you're competitive when it comes to that, but when it comes to other parts of your life, hang back a little bit. You know, you don't care as much. Yeah. So definitely people are more competitive in what they find to be self-relevant. So for example, if you play tennis, then you're going to be more competitive at tennis than, you know, another game like golf or something like that.
Do people tend to be competitive in all aspects of their lives, or is it more common, say, for somebody to, you know, you're an athlete, so you're competitive when it comes to that, but when it comes to other parts of your life, hang back a little bit. You know, you don't care as much. Yeah. So definitely people are more competitive in what they find to be self-relevant. So for example, if you play tennis, then you're going to be more competitive at tennis than, you know, another game like golf or something like that.|||人们在生活的所有方面都往往具有好胜心吗？还是说更常见的情况是，比如一个人，你知道的，你是一名运动员，所以在涉及这方面时你很有好胜心，但到了生活的其他部分，就会稍微收敛一点？你知道的，你没那么在乎。是的。因此，人们肯定在他们认为与自我相关的事情上更具好胜心。例如，如果你打网球，那么你在网球上就会比在网球之外的另一项运动（比如高尔夫球之类的）更具好胜心。
So it is in these domains. which we see as being relevant is where we exercise our competition. That said, it is possible to also be competitive in situations where it's really not that personally relevant. For example, just if you look at childhood games, for example, I think many of us might remember when we were children, people would say, first one to the tree is the coolest person in the world, or last one, there's a rotten A. And in both of these cases, you know, the children run.
So it is in these domains. which we see as being relevant is where we exercise our competition. That said, it is possible to also be competitive in situations where it's really not that personally relevant. For example, just if you look at childhood games, for example, I think many of us might remember when we were children, people would say, first one to the tree is the coolest person in the world, or last one, there's a rotten A. And in both of these cases, you know, the children run.|||因此，正是在这些我们认为相关的领域中，我们才施展我们的竞争。话虽如此，在那些与个人其实并没有那么相关的情境中，也有可能产生好胜心。例如，如果你看看童年的游戏，我想我们很多人可能都还记得，当我们还是孩子的时候，人们会说，第一个跑到树下的人是世界上最酷的人，或者最后一个跑到的人是个烂苹果（rotten egg）。在这两种情况下，你知道的，孩子们都会跑。
I mean, if you would say that with a group of adults and if they're able to run or mobilize their walker, I mean, you might have a similar kind of effect going on. So it's not like, you know, we're all trying to get to the tree and that's what it, you know, that's very self-relevant. I mean, it's not the conventional domain of competition, but I think it sort of illustrates how this competitiveness or the competitive spirit can be awakened, even in ephemeral. non-consequential situations. When we compete against someone who is better than us, does that tend to make us perform
I mean, if you would say that with a group of adults and if they're able to run or mobilize their walker, I mean, you might have a similar kind of effect going on. So it's not like, you know, we're all trying to get to the tree and that's what it, you, that's very self-relevant. I mean, it's not the conventional domain of competition, but I think it sort of illustrates how this competitiveness or the competitive spirit can be awakened, even in ephemeral. non-consequential situations. When we compete against someone who is better than us, does that tend to make us perform|||我的意思是，如果你对一群成年人说这句话，如果他们还能跑或者能推着助行器移动，我的意思是，你可能会产生类似的效果。所以这并不是说，你知道的，我们都在努力跑到树那儿，这就是它，你，这与自我高度相关。我的意思是，这不是传统的竞争领域，但我认为这在某种程度上说明了这种好胜心或竞争精神是如何被唤醒的，即使是在短暂的、无关紧要的情境中。当我们与比我们优秀的人竞争时，这往往会让我们表现得|||
better or worse, or is there no effect? So definitely if you try to compete with someone who's better than you, I mean, it would serve as a nice anchor for you to actually try to achieve that level. And in some ways, even people with growth mindsets, for example, even if they're not competing with other people per se, they might look to others as being exemplars on where they would like to go in terms of their trajectory. And so that would be another way where people are more inspired by, you know, high anchors. I mean, you could just think about like, you know, with whom would you prefer to play a game of tennis, someone who's worse than you or
better or worse, or is there no effect? So definitely if you try to compete with someone who's better than you, I mean, it would serve as a nice anchor for you to actually try to achieve that level. And in some ways, even people with growth mindsets, for example, even if they're not competing with other people per se, they might look to others as being exemplars on where they would like to go in terms of their trajectory. And so that would be another way where people are more inspired by, you know, high anchors. I mean, you could just think about like, you know, with whom would you prefer to play a game of tennis, someone who's worse than you or|||更好还是更差，还是说没有什么影响？所以毫无疑问，如果你试图与一个比你优秀的人竞争，我的意思是，它会成为一个很好的锚点，让你真正尝试去达到那个水平。在某些方面，甚至拥有成长型思维模式的人，例如，即使他们本身并不在与其他人竞争，他们也可能会将其他人视为榜样，以此作为他们未来发展轨迹的参考。因此，这也是人们更容易受到（你知道的）高锚点启发的一种方式。我的意思是，你可以想想，你知道的，你更愿意和谁打一场网球，是一个比你差的人，还是
someone who's, you know, slightly better than you. If you play with a person slightly better than you, that's where you're really going to learn to improve your own game. What makes a rivalry healthy and conversely what makes one unhealthy? In some rivalries, they're not built on a closer, amicable or respectful relationship. And when you do not have that kind of a rivalry, then you're going to see more untoward behaviors or you're going to see more unethical behaviors. So, I mean, if you think about, I always think about figure skating and how I think Tanya Harding was the one who broke the legs or injured the legs of Nancy Kerrigan, I believe.
someone who's, you know, slightly better than you. If you play with a person slightly better than you, that's where you're really going to learn to improve your own game. What makes a rivalry healthy and conversely what makes one unhealthy? In some rivalries, they're not built on a closer, amicable or respectful relationship. And when you do not have that kind of a rivalry, then you're going to see more untoward behaviors or you're going to see more unethical behaviors. So, I mean, if you think about, I always think about figure skating and how I think Tanya Harding was the one who broke the legs or injured the legs of Nancy Kerrigan, I believe.|||一个（你知道的）比你稍微好一点的人。如果你和一个比你稍好一点的人一起打球，这才是你真正能够学会提升自己球技的地方。是什么让竞争关系保持健康，反之又是什么让它变得不健康？在某些竞争关系中，它们并非建立在更加亲密、友好或相互尊重的基础之上。当你没有那种竞争关系时，你就会看到更多乖张的行为，或者你会看到更多不道德的行为。所以，我的意思是，如果你想想，我总是想起花样滑冰，我想托妮亚·哈丁（Tanya Harding）就是那个打断了南希·克里根（Nancy Kerrigan）的腿或弄伤了她的腿的人，如果我没记错的话。
And so, I mean, that was an example of a rivalry and that wasn't necessarily a healthy rivalry. But there are rivalries where you can have rivals who actually do respect each other and they might play, you know, a tough game with each other. but then once they're done with the game, that's it. They're able to engage in amicable relations with each other. Is competitiveness innate in humans? I'm just wondering whether evolution might argue more strongly for cooperation versus competition when it comes to survival.
And so, I mean, that was an example of a rivalry and that wasn't necessarily a healthy rivalry. But there's rivalries where you can have rivals who actually do respect each other and they might play, you know, a tough game with each other. but then once they're done with the game, that's it. They're able to engage in amicable relations with each other. Is competitiveness innate in humans? I'm just wondering whether evolution might argue more strongly for cooperation versus competition when it comes to survival.|||所以，我的意思是，那是一个竞争关系的例子，而且那不一定是健康的竞争关系。但也有些竞争关系，竞争对手之间确实彼此尊重，他们可能会进行一场（你知道的）激烈的比赛。但一旦比赛结束，就结束了。他们能够彼此保持友好的关系。好胜心是人类与生俱来的吗？我只是在想，在生存方面，进化论是否会更强烈地支持合作而非竞争。
You know, I'm not like an evolutionary psychologist or a biologist, but I would definitely say that there's competitive processes not only in humans, but also in primates, and also, I believe, even in cockroaches. So the reason why I say that is Bob Zions, you know, many years ago, did this one study looking at social facilitation, and he had the cockroaches in a maze. And basically, the cockroaches, if they were by themselves versus with a few others, the cockroach. the cockroaches who were by themselves, I don't recall the exact measure, but they were slower to get where they needed to go compared to those that were amongst a few trying to get to probably a source of food.
You know, I'm not like an evolutionary psychologist or a biologist, but I would definitely say that there's competitive processes not only in humans, but also in primates, and also, I believe, even in cockroaches. So the reason why I say that is Bob Zions, you know, many years ago, did this one study looking at social facilitation, and he had the cockroaches in a maze. And basically, the cockroaches, if they were by themselves versus with a few others, the cockroach. the cockroaches who were by themselves, I don't recall the exact measure, but they were slower to get where they needed to go compared to those that were amongst a few trying to get to probably a source of food.|||你知道的，我不是什么进化心理学家或生物学家，但我肯定会说，不仅人类存在竞争过程，灵长类动物中也存在，而且我相信，甚至连蟑螂都有。我之所以这么说，是因为鲍勃·扎荣茨（Bob Zajonc）在很多年前做过一项关于社会助长的研究，他把蟑螂放在一个迷宫里。基本上，蟑螂如果是自己待着，与和另外几只蟑螂在一起时相比，那些自己待着的蟑螂——我不记得具体的测量指标了——它们到达目的地速度比那些在几只蟑螂当中、可能正努力寻找食物源的蟑螂要慢。
The other thing that I might have for, let's say, a biologist or an arborist, for example, is like what does the distance between trees mean? and like do the trees actually emit something if there's a tree that's growing too close to them or what can actually turn on or turn off competitive behavior, so to speak, from a tree's perspective. I'm sure there's those dynamics that exist. I just don't know them. Right. And that depends on which way you're looking at it from, because you could say that's also cooperative. You know, I need my space, so you just have to grow over there a little bit and then we can both grow. Right, exactly.
The other thing that I might have for, let's say, a biologist or an arborist, for example, is like what does the distance between trees mean? and like do the trees actually emit something if there's a tree that's growing too close to them or what can actually turn on or turn off competitive behavior, so to speak, from a tree's perspective. I'm sure there's those dynamics that exist. I just don't know them. Right. And that depends on which way you're looking at it from, because you could say that's also cooperative. You know, I need my space, so you just have to grow over there a little bit and then we can both grow. Right, exactly.|||另一件我可能会问（比如说）生物学家或树木学家的事情是，树木之间的距离意味着什么？比如，如果有一棵树生长得离它们太近，树木本身是否会释放出什么物质，或者从树木的角度来看，到底是什么开启或关闭了所谓的竞争行为。我确信这些动态是存在的。我只是不知道罢了。没错。这取决于你从哪个角度来看，因为你也可以说这也是一种合作。你知道的，我需要我的空间，所以你必须往那边多长一点，然后我们俩都能生长。没错，完全正确。
Yes. Yeah. Well, let's talk for a minute about gender as a factor. So do men and women differ in their willingness to compete or how they respond to competitive settings? Yeah. So there's been research, especially from behavioral economics, showing that in general, men would be more likely to enter a competitive situation such as a tournament, whereas women would prefer something that's less competitive or non-competitive,
Yes. Yeah. Well, let's talk for a minute about gender as a factor. So do men and women differ in their willingness to compete or how they respond to competitive settings? Yeah. So there's been research, especially from behavioral economics, showing that in general, men would be more likely to enter a competitive situation such as a tournament, whereas women would prefer something that's less competitive or non-competitive,|||是的。是的。好吧，我们花一分钟来聊聊性别作为一个因素。那么，男女在竞争意愿或对竞争环境的反应上有什么不同吗？是的。有些研究，尤其是来自行为经济学的研究表明，总体而言，男性更有可能进入竞争激烈的环境（如锦标赛），而女性则更喜欢竞争较少或不具竞争性的环境，
such as a pay-as-you-go rate. So there was a study that was done that showed that men prefer to enter a tournament-style competition versus get paid for a task based on a piece rate method. And so that's one of the differences. Another thing that would also differ is in terms of what we'd call entry decisions into competition. So there you might get the idea. that women would shy away from competitions. And so my collaborator, Catherine Hannock, led a study where we looked at how the gender of the
such as a pay-as-you-go rate. So there was a study that was done that showed that men prefer to enter a tournament-style competition versus get paid for a task based on a piece rate method. And so that's one of the differences. Another thing that would also differ is in terms of what we'd call entry decisions into competition. So there you might get the idea. that women would shy away from competitions. And so my collaborator, Catherine Hannock, led a study where we looked at how the gender of the|||例如按件计酬费率。因此，曾有一项研究表明，男性倾向于参加锦标赛式的竞争，而不是根据计件工资方法为某项任务获得报酬。这就是区别之一。另一个会有所不同的方面是我们所谓的进入竞争的决策。所以你可能会有这样的想法：女性会回避竞争。因此，我的合作者凯瑟琳·哈诺克（Catherine Hannock）主导了一项研究，我们探讨了以下因素如何影响
competitor can also affect what size of competition they prefer to enter. So in these studies that were led by Catherine Hannock, we had two situations. We had a competition where there were many competitors, let's say 100 competitors, and we had a situation where there was a competition with 10 competitors. And we gave men and women preferences in terms of which competition they would like to enter, and we held constant the expected value of winning. How likely is it that you would actually win? So it was held constant.
competitor can also affect what size of competition they prefer to enter. So in these studies that were led by Catherine Hannock, we had two situations. We had a competition where there were many competitors, let's say 100 competitors, and we had a situation where there was a competition with 10 competitors. And we gave men and women preferences in terms of which competition they would like to enter, and we held constant the expected value of winning. How likely is it that you would actually win? So it was held constant.|||竞争对手的性别：竞争对手的性别也会影响他们倾向于进入什么规模的竞争。因此，在由凯瑟琳·哈诺克主导的这些研究中，我们有两种情境。我们有一种竞争，里面有很多竞争对手，比方说 100 个竞争对手；我们还有一种情境，里面有 10 个竞争对手。我们让男女表达他们更愿意参加哪种竞争的偏好，并且我们保持获胜的期望值恒定。你实际获胜的可能性有多大？所以它是保持恒定的。
And what we found was that men gravitated toward larger competitions, whereas women gravitated toward smaller competitions, relatively speaking. And so, you know, again, I was, Catherine was the lead author here, And so what her theory suggested was that women feel more comfortable in smaller spaces or amongst fewer people rather than many. And that was part of the reason why they were gravitating toward the smaller competitions compared to the larger ones at greater rates than men were. What about cultural differences? How do people in different countries or cultures respond to competition? are they different from Americans?
And what we found was that men gravitated toward larger competitions, whereas women gravitated toward smaller competitions, relatively speaking. And so, youening again, I was, Catherine was the lead author here, And so what her theory suggested was that women feel more comfortable in smaller spaces or amongst fewer people rather than many. And that was part of the reason why they were gravitating toward the smaller competitions compared to the larger ones at greater rates than men were. What about cultural differences? How do people in different countries or cultures respond to competition? are they different from Americans?|||我们发现的是，男性倾向于规模更大的竞争，而女性相对而言更倾向于规模较小的竞争。因此，（再次回到刚才的话题）凯瑟琳是这里的首席作者，所以她的理论表明，女性在较小的空间或较少的人群中会感到更舒适，而不是人多的时候。这也是为什么与男性相比，她们以更高的比例倾向于规模较小的竞争而不是规模较大的竞争的部分原因。文化差异呢？不同国家或文化背景的人对竞争作何反应？他们和美国人有什么不同吗？
Because we tend to be very competitive in this country. Right. So there was another paper that a former student led Katie Wu in this case. And so what we did was we looked at how Chinese research participants would choose to enter a different competition compared to an American research participant. And basically we were looking at what's called the Frog Pondifact. And that's the general idea that if given the choice to be, you know, the big frog in a small pond versus a small frog in a big pond, which would you prefer?
Because we're tend to be very competitive in this country. Right. So there was another paper that a former student led Katie Wu in this case. And so what we did was we looked at how Chinese research participants would choose to enter a different competition compared to an American research participant. And basically we were looking at what's called the Frog Pondifact. And that's the general idea that if given the choice to be, you know, the big frog in a small pond versus a small frog in a big pond, which would you prefer?|||因为在这个国家，我们往往非常有竞争力。没错。因此，还有另一篇论文由一名前学生主导——在这个案例中是凯蒂·吴（Katie Wu）。我们所做的是，研究中国研究参与者在选择参与不同竞争时，与美国研究参与者有何不同。基本上我们研究的是所谓的“大鱼小池塘效应”（Frog Pond Effect）。这是一个普遍的观点，即如果给你选择成为（你知道的）小池塘里的大青蛙，还是大池塘里的小青蛙，你更喜欢哪一个？
And the conventional wisdom is that people prefer to be the big frog in a small pond. And so the idea there is being the big frog, you're the big person. And the small pond you might think of as being a lower status. And so you'd rather be in a situation where you're, the big guy number one, even if the broader group is lower status compared to being a little guy in a high status group. And so basically that is what we found in this research is that Americans tended to prefer to be the big frog in the small pond. However, Eastern Asians and Chinese participants in our sample were more inclined for the opposite. They preferred to be maybe an average
And the conventional wisdom is that people prefer to be the big frog in a small pond. And so the idea there is being the big frog, you're the big person. And the small pond you might think of as being a lower status. And so you'd rather be in a situation where you're, the big guy number one, even if the broader group is lower status compared to being a little guy in a high status group. And so basically that is what we found in this research is that Americans tended to prefer to be the big frog in the small pond. However, Eastern Asians and Chinese participants in our sample were more inclined for the opposite. They preferred to be maybe an average|||传统观念认为，人们更喜欢做小池塘里的大青蛙。所以那里的想法是，作为大青蛙，你就是大人物。而小池塘你可能会认为地位较低。因此，你宁愿处于这样一种情况：你是第一大人物，即使与身处高地位群体中的小人物相比，更广泛的群体地位较低。基本上，这就是我们在本研究中发现的：美国人倾向于喜欢做小池塘里的大青蛙。然而，我们样本中的东亚人和中国参与者更倾向于相反的选择。他们更愿意成为一个可能
size fish in a large pond in the more, you know, what you would call a more high status pond. And they did not want to necessarily be the big fish in the small pond. We're going to take a short break. When we come back, I'll talk with Dr. Garcia about whether it's necessary to be competitive if you want to achieve big things and about how to deal with the overly competitive people in your life. It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that
size fish in a large pond in the more, youening know, what you would call a more high status pond. And they did not want to necessarily be the big fish in the small pond. We're going to take a short break. When we come back, I'll talk with Dr. Garcia about whether it's necessary to be competitive if you're want to achieve big things and about how to deal with the overly competitive people in your life. It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that|||大池塘里大小适中的鱼，在一个（你知道的）你称之为更高地位的池塘里。他们不一定想成为小池塘里的大鱼。我们稍作休息。广告回来后，我将与加西亚博士探讨，如果想成就大事，是否有必要具备好胜心，以及如何应对你生活中的过度好胜之人。正值授粉高峰期，我的业务正在迅速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这真是一个
doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. Google FiWireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See homedepot.com slash price match for details.
doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. Google FiWireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See homedepot.com slash price match for details.|||转瞬即逝的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需税费和政府规费。在网络高峰期，Google FiWireless 不会遭遇数据流量降速。家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日特惠活动让你的夏天即刻开启。是时候用特价仅售 199 美元的 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烧烤炉开启夏日烧烤了。整个季节尽情招待亲友，只需 49 美元即可拥有汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐桌椅。今年阵亡将士纪念日，尽在家得宝享受超低价格保证。数量有限，售完即止，促销价有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用免责条款。详情请参见 homedepot.com/price-match。
How much does competitiveness correlate with success? Do you have to be extremely competitive to achieve big things in the world? So, I mean, some people are able to achieve without much effort, and some people are able to achieve just based on strategic thinking. And other people have to work hard to become successful. And I think, you know, in that, among that group, yeah, I think being competitive and having a competitive spirit, a healthy competitive spirit can help propel you, can help advance you. Of course, it becomes deleterious if you just, if you see every little competition as being the end all of everything and it's not. So long as you just approach it as, you know, this is just kind of like one battle in a broader war. If you want to use that metaphor, I think that would.
How much does competitiveness correlate with success? Do you have to be extremely competitive to achieve big things in the world? So, I mean, some people are able to achieve without much effort, and some people are able to achieve just based on strategic thinking. And other people have to work hard to become successful. And I think, youening in that, among that group, yeah, I think being competitive and having a competitive spirit, a healthy competitive spirit can help propel you, can help advance you. Of course, it becomes deleterious if you just, if you see every little competition as being the end all of everything and it's not. So long as you just approach it as, you know, this is just kind of like one battle in a broader war. If you want to use that metaphor, I think that would.|||好胜心与成功的关联度有多大？要想在世界上成就大事，你必须极具好胜心吗？所以，我的意思是，有些人无需付出太大努力就能取得成就，有些人仅凭战略思维就能取得成就。而另一些人则必须努力工作才能成功。我认为，你知道的，在这个群体中，是的，我认为具有好胜心和竞争精神——一种健康的竞争精神——可以帮助推动你前进，帮助你取得进步。当然，如果你只是把每一场小竞争都看作是一切的终结，那就另当别论了，然而事实并非如此。只要你以这种方式看待它：这只是一场更宏大战争中的一场战役而已。如果你想用这个比喻的话，我认为那会
would be another more healthy way to look at it. But yes, I do think that among some people, competitiveness can help people achieve greater things. I mean, we even see this in terms of like group processes or intergroup relations. So even like, let's say, you know, success among nations, that rivalry that you had experienced between one country versus another. I mean, that has helped, I would think, you know,
would be another more healthly way to look at it. But yes, I do think that among some people, competitiveness can help people achieve greater things. I mean, we even see this in terms of like group processes or intergroup relations. So even like, let's say, youening know, (success among nations, that rivalry that you had experienced between one country versus another. I mean, that has helped, I would think, youening know,|||是另一种更健康的看待方式。但是的，我确实认为，对某些人来说，好胜心可以帮助人们取得更大的成就。我的意思是，我们甚至在群际过程或群际关系方面也能看到这一点。因此，甚至像是，比如说，（国家之间的成功，你曾在某国与另一国之间经历过的竞争。我的意思是，这有助于，我想，你知道的，
help foster innovation in ingenuity, et cetera. You know, and so you can think about that in many different levels, not only just an individual trying to become more innovative, but even the groups to which they belong and the broader, you know, identities that they relate to, et cetera. I mean, that could also be, you know, a factor of competition and achievement. Yeah. It would seem that competitiveness would have to be just one of a number of important
help foster innovation in ingenuity, et cetera. Youening know, and so you can think about that in many different levels, not only just an individual trying to become more innovative, but even the groups to which they belong and the broader, youening identities that they relate to, et cetera. I mean, that could also be, youening know, a factor of competition and achievement. Yeah. It would seem that competitiveness would have to be just one of a number of important|||帮助培养创新和独创性等等。你知道的，所以你可以从许多不同的层面去思考这个问题，不仅是一个试图变得更有创新精神的个人，甚至还包括他们所属的群体以及他们所联系的更广泛的身份认同等等。我的意思是，这也可能是一个（你知道的）竞争和成就的因素。是的。看起来好胜心必然只是众多重要因素中的一个而已。
factors when it comes to achieving big things. I mean, if you think about a lot of people who say go to Hollywood or New York and they want to be actors, and how many times do you have to be shot down, turned down when you try out for pieces before you finally get your big break? Right. No, and I think that would be sort of an example where, you know, the concept of grit would be helpful perhaps, just going ahead and biting the bullet, persevering and yeah, just putting more effort in it, not letting the headwinds bother you, just go against the headwinds. And so over time, that persistence could help you attain more than if you had no grit, so to speak.
factors when it comes to achieving big things. I mean, if you think about a lot of people who say go to Hollywood or New York and they want to be actors, and how many times do you have to be shot down, turned down when you try out for pieces before you finally get your big break? Right. No, and I think that would be sort of an example where, youening know, the concept of grit would be helpful perhaps, just going ahead and biting the bullet, persevering and yeah, just putting more effort in it, not letting the headwinds bother you, just go against the headwinds. And so over time, that persistence could help you attain more than if you had no grit, so to speak.|||当谈到成就大业时。我的意思是，如果你想想很多去好莱坞或纽约想成为演员的人，在试镜时你必须被拒绝、被回绝多少次，才能最终迎来你的重大机遇？没错。不，我认为这将是一个例子，其中（你知道的）坚毅（grit）的概念可能会很有帮助，就是咬紧牙关，坚持不懈，是的，只要在其中投入更多的努力，不要让逆境困扰你，迎着逆境前进。因此，随着时间的推移，这种坚持可以帮助你获得比没有坚毅品质更多东西，可以说是这样的。
Oh, we have to talk to Angela Duckworth, I guess. Yeah, definitely. Yeah, she's the grit person. Yes, she is. Is it possible to be too competitive? I mean, what are the downsides of competitiveness? Yeah, so, I mean, it's definitely possible to be too competitive, especially because there can be some dark areas or dark consequences of being super competitive,
Oh, we have to talk to Angela Duckworth, I guess. Yeah, definitely. Yeah, she's the grit person. Yes, she is. Is it possible to be too competitive? I mean, what are the downsides of competitiveness? Yeah, so, I mean, it's definitely possible to be too competitive, especially because there can be some dark areas or dark consequences of being super competitive,|||哦，我想我们得去采访一下安杰拉·达克沃思（Angela Duckworth）。是的，绝对的。是的，她就是那位“坚毅女神”。是的，她正是。好胜心太强是可能的吗？我的意思是，好胜心的负面影响是什么？是的，所以，我的意思是，好胜心太强绝对是可能的，特别是由于超级好胜可能会带来一些黑暗地带或黑暗后果，
yet not making your goal. So you might have attacks on your self-esteem. It may give you the delusion that you have no self-worth if you don't achieve some kind of goal that you were trying to achieve. So I think there is a dark side to being too. competitive. We end up with no friends. Yeah, right, right.
yet not making your goal. So you might have attacks on your self-esteem. It may give you the delusion that you have no self-worth if you don't achieve some kind of goal that you were trying to achieve. So I think there is a dark side to being too. competitive. We end up with no friends. Yeah, right, right.|||却没有达成你的目标。所以你可能会遭遇对你自尊心的打击。如果你没有实现某种你试图实现的目标，它可能会给你带来一种错觉，让你觉得自己毫无自我价值。所以我认为好胜心太强确实有黑暗面。我们最后落得没有朋友。是的，没错，没错。
And also you can think of it as being, you know, stealing your joy. So, for example, you know, one thing that I always think about is sometimes if I'm in an elevator, for example, staying at a fancy hotel. And if I mean a subsidized fancy hotel. But if I'm staying at a hotel for a conference or something like that. And usually these are like high rises, you know, if I'm. I'm staying on the 22nd floor, and then someone comes in, the elevator, and then they'd say to me, oh, can you hit floor 25, please? And it's like, you know, if you're really competitive, sometimes I'm that way.
And also you can think of it as being, youening know, stealing your joy. So, for example, youening know, one thing that I always think about is sometimes if I'm in an elevator, for example, staying at a fancy hotel. And if I mean a subsidized fancy hotel. But if I'm staying at a hotel for a conference or something like that. And usually these are like high rises, youening know, if I'm. I'm staying on the 22nd floor, and then someone comes in, the elevator, and then they'd say to me, oh, can you hit floor 25, please? And it's like, youening know, if you're really competitive, sometimes I'm that way.|||你也可以把它看作是（你知道的）偷走你的快乐。所以，例如，（你知道的）我经常想到的一件事是，有时如果我在电梯里，比如住在一家高级酒店里。如果我是说一家有补贴的高级酒店。但如果我是为了开会之类的原因住在酒店里。通常这些都是像高层建筑一样，（你知道的）如果我。我住在 22 层，然后有人走进电梯，接着他们对我说：“哦，能帮我按一下 25 层吗？”这就好像，（你知道的）如果你真的很好胜——有时我就是那样。
I think like, oh, man, they're just trying to what up me and show their glory that they're staying on the 25th floor, and I'm only on the 22nd floor. So really that could be an example where it's just competitiveness that is stealing, you know, your joy. And of course, the view is just as good from the 22nd floor as the 25th or whatever. But it's really a killer if that's the club level and you're not on it. Oh, there you go. Yeah. Holy, yeah, for sure.
I think like, oh, man, they're just trying to what up me and show their glory that they're staying on the 25th floor, and I'm only on the 22nd floor. So really that could be an example where it's just competitiveness that is stealing, youening know, your joy. And of course, the view is just as good from the 22nd floor as the 25th or whatever. But it's really a killer if that's the club level and you're not on it. Oh, there you go. Yeah. Holy, yeah, for sure.|||我想着，天哪，他们只是想压我一头，炫耀他们住在 25 层而我只住在 22 层的荣耀。所以这真的是一个例子，证明正是好胜心在（你知道的）偷走你的快乐。当然，从 22 层看到的风景和 25 层或者其他楼层一样好。但如果那是行政酒层（club level）而你又不在那一层，那可真要命。哦，原来如此。是的。天哪，是的，确实如此。
Holy mackerel. Now, you've also studied something called the status symbol paradox, the disconnect between what people think will help them make friends and what actually does. How does that relate to competition? Yeah, so sometimes I think what happens is when we're trying to make new, friends, we're almost in a competitive mindset in terms of what's going to attract new friends. So imagine, you know, you're recently graduated from college and you moved to a new town. And so what we did was we asked research participants, you know, this scenario.
Holy mackerel. Now, you've also studied something called the status symbol paradox, the disconnect between what people think will help them make friends and what actually does. How does that relate to competition? Yeah, so sometimes I think what happens is when we're trying to make new, friends, we're almost in a competitive mindset in terms of what's going to attract new friends. So imagine, youening know, you're recently graduated from college and you moved to a new town. And so what we did was we asked research participants, youening know, this scenario.|||我的天呐。现在，你还研究过一种被称为“地位象征悖论”的东西，即人们以为能帮自己交到朋友的东西与实际能交到朋友的东西之间存在脱节。这与竞争有什么关系？是的，有时我认为发生的情况是，当我们试图结交新朋友时，我们在什么能吸引新朋友方面几乎处于一种竞争心态。所以想象一下，（你知道的）你刚从大学毕业，搬到了一座新城镇。因此，我们所做的是，我们向研究参与者询问了（你知道的）这种情境。
And if you're moving to a new town, suppose, you know, you could buy a new car and money wasn't an issue. You could either buy, you know, a Honda Civic or a Honda Accord, I believe, or you could buy a BMW 3 series, which would you buy to make new friends in this new community? Well, when we ask people, they're more inclined to buy the BMW because they think the BMW is going to help them make more close friends. But on the flip side, when we ask, you know, people, research participants in the would-be friend condition, we say, oh, imagine there's, you know, a recent college grad that just moved to the community and they pulled up in a Honda or another group.
And if you're new to a new town, suppose, youening know, you could buy a new car and money wasn't an issue. You could either buy, youening know, a Honda Civic or a Honda Accord, I believe, or you could buy a BMW 3 series, which would you buy to make new friends in this new community? Well, when we ask people, they're more inclined to buy the BMW because they think the BMW is going to help them make more close friends. But on the flip side, when we ask, youening know, people, research participants in the would-be friend condition, we say, oh, imagine there's, youening know, a recent college grad that just moved to the community and they pulled up in a Honda or another group.|||如果你刚到一个新城镇，假设，（你知道的）你可以买一辆新车，而且钱不是问题。你可以买（你知道的）一辆本田思域（Honda Civic）或本田雅阁（Honda Accord），我想，或者你可以买一辆宝马 3 系，为了在这个新社区结交新朋友，你会买哪一个？当我们问人们时，他们更倾向于买宝马，因为他们认为宝马会帮助他们结交更多亲密的朋友。但在另一方面，当我们问（你知道的）处于“潜在朋友”情境中的人、研究参与者时，我们说：“哦，想象一下，有一个（你知道的）刚搬到社区的应届大学毕业生，他们开着一辆本田车来到这里”或者另一组。
of participants, we said they pulled up in a BMW. And what we found was that people wanted to become friends with the person driving the Honda. They didn't want to become friends with the person driving the BMW. And so that's kind of like in our effort to seek new friends, we're using status to make us seem more appealing, you know, in this world of making friends, but we're actually repelling would-be friends. They don't want to be friends with the person who is signaling status. So in some ways, that's kind of an error in the way people think about making close friends. It's not a competition where you need to show like all the status that you have. People actually like neutral non-status signaling friends. Do you have any advice for
of participants, we said they pulled up in a BMW. And what we found was that people wanted to become friends with the person driving the Honda. They didn't want to become friends with the person driving the BMW. And so that's kind of like in our effort to seek new friends, we're using status to make us seem more appealing, youening know, in this world of making friends, but we're actually repelling would-be friends. They don't want to be friends with the person who is signaling status. So in some ways, that's kind of an error in the way people think about making close friends. It's not a competition where you need to show like all the status that you have. People actually like neutral non-status signaling friends. Do you have any advice for|||参与者，我们说他们开着一辆宝马车来。我们发现的是，人们更愿意与开本田车的人做朋友。他们不想与开宝马车的人做朋友。所以这有点像我们在努力寻找新朋友时，利用地位来让自己显得更有吸引力，（你知道的）在这个交友的世界里，但我们实际上却在排斥潜在的朋友。他们不想与那个彰显地位的人做朋友。所以在某种程度上，这可以说是人们思考如何结交密友方式上的一种错误。这不是一场你需要展示你所拥有的所有地位的竞争。人们其实更喜欢不彰显地位的中立朋友。您有什么建议吗？
dealing with an overly competitive friend or even a relative in your life? Yeah. So I sometimes think about my my uncle ernie my uncle ernie would always ask me how i was doing then he would always bring up like my cousin john my cousin john ruiz is a is a psychology professor at university of arizona and so whenever i would see uncle ernie he would be like oh how are you doing and i'm not doing okay and then he would tell me all about cousin john oh uh cousin john he's he's got another big grant, you know, that he recently got or cousin John, he's going back to D.C. to be on another grant panel or something like that. I think it was called National Science Foundation. And so like, whatever I would see, Uncle Erdo would be like, oh, my gosh, you know, what am I going to do?
dealing with an overly competitive friend or even a relative in your life? Yeah. So I sometimes think about my my uncle ernie my uncle ernie would always ask me how i was doing then he would always bring up like my cousin john my cousin john ruiz is a is a psychology professor at university of arizona and so whenever i would see uncle ernie he would be like oh how are you doing and i'm not doing okay and then he would tell me all about cousin john oh uh cousin john he's he's got another big grant, you know, that he recently got or cousin John, he's going back to D.C. to be on another grant panel or something like that. I think it was called National Science Foundation. And so like, whatever I would see, Uncle Erdo would be like, oh, my gosh, youening know, what am I going to do?|||关于如何应对生活中一个过度好胜的朋友，甚至是亲戚？是的。有时我会想起我的厄尼叔叔（Uncle Ernie）。我的厄尼叔叔总是问我最近怎么样，然后他总是会提起我的表哥约翰。我的表哥约翰·鲁伊斯（John Ruiz）是亚利桑那大学的心理学教授。所以每次我见到厄尼叔叔时，他就会说：“哦，你最近怎么样？”而我其实过得并不太好，接着他就会滔滔不绝地跟我讲表哥约翰的事：“哦，呃，表哥约翰他又拿到了一笔大额科研经费（你知道的），他最近刚拿到的”或者“表哥约翰又要回华盛顿特区去参加另一个资助评审小组之类的了”。我想那叫国家科学基金会。所以就像，无论什么时候我看到，厄尼叔叔都会说：“哦，天哪，（你知道的）我该怎么办呢？”
And so, I mean, maybe you could still steer the conversation in a different direction and you could just, you know, change the subject. But from that Uncle Ernie experience, I mean, it struck me that even a third party by asking and comparing you to someone else, they could kind of mint a rivalry even where it didn't previously exist. But I think, you know, taking advantage of competitive situations and making them more pleasant experiences. So it might be watching games together, watching, football together, watching, baseball together, or it might be. might be organizing some kind of a game in the backyard if you can or something like that. So actually making some positive social aspect out of that competitive spirit that a family member may have. But then you have to be prepared to lose, right?
And so, I mean, maybe you could still steer the conversation in a different direction and you could just, youening know, change the subject. But from that Uncle Ernie experience, I mean, it struck me that even a third party by asking and comparing you to someone else, they could kind of mint a rivalry even where it didn't previously exist. But I think, youening know, taking advantage of competitive situations and making them more pleasant experiences. So it might be watching games together, watching, football together, watching, baseball together, or it might be. might be organizing some kind of a game in the backyard if you can or something like that. So actually making some positive social aspect out of that competitive spirit that a family member may have. But then you have to be prepared to lose, right?|||所以，我的意思是，也许你仍然可以把谈话引导到另一个方向，你可以（你知道的）转移话题。但从那次厄尼叔叔的经历中，我的意思是，我突然意识到，即使是第三方通过询问并将你与其他人进行比较，他们也可以凭空捏造出一种竞争关系，尽管这种关系以前并不存在。但我认为，（你知道的）利用竞争情境并将其变成更愉快的体验。所以这可能是一起看比赛，一起看橄榄球，一起看棒球，或者可能是。如果可能的话，在后院组织某种游戏之类的。因此，实际上是从家庭成员可能拥有的这种好胜心中创造出一些积极的社交层面。但那样的话，你就得做好失败的准备，对吧？
Right. Then you'd have to be prepared to lose. And so, yeah, that would be the difficult part for sure. How did you get interested in this subject? Are you a competitive guy? When I was writing up my dissertation, I had an opportunity to go for a year at the, what it was called the program on, it is called the program on negotiation at Harvard Law School. So I was finishing up my PhD at Princeton.
Right. Then you'd have to be prepared to lose. And so, yeah, that would be the difficult part for sure. How did you get interested in this subject? Are you a competitive guy? When I was writing up my dissertation, I had an opportunity to go for a year at the, what it was called the program on, it is called the program on negotiation at Harvard Law School. So I was finishing up my PhD at Princeton.|||没错。那你必须做好失败的准备。所以，是的，那绝对是困难的部分。你是怎么对这个课题感兴趣的？你是个好胜的人吗？在我写博士论文的时候，我有机会去（当时被称为）那个项目待一年，它被称为哈佛法学院的谈判项目（Program on Negotiation）。当时我正在普林斯顿大学攻读博士学位。
And while there, I met my good friend and collaborator, Avi Shalom Tour. And Avi Shalom Tour was a law and economics person. So he was in the Harvard's like SJD program, which is kind of like a, Ph.D. version of a JD. Anyway, so when I was describing to him my dissertation, I mean, it was, it was actually Avi Shalom that sort of said, oh, well, you're studying basically the psychology of competition in so many words. He suggested that. And it was interesting because in social psychology, really, there had been a lull in the study of competitive behavior and competition. And so Avi Shalom Torr, who is, you know, new psychology and economics, he was able to use that language.
And while there, I met my good friend and collaborator, Avi Shalom Tour. And Avi Shalom Tour was a law and economics person. So he was in the Harvard's like SJD program, which is kind of like a, Ph.D. version of a JD. Anyway, so when I was describing to him my dissertation, I mean, it was, it was actually Avi Shalom that sort of said, oh, well, you're studying basically the psychology of competition in so many words. He suggested that. And it was interesting because in social psychology, really, there had been a lull in the study of competitive behavior and competition. And so Avi Shalom Torr, who is, youening know, new psychology and economics, he was able to use that language.|||在那里，我遇到了我的好朋友兼合作者阿维·沙洛姆·托尔（Avi Shalom Torr）。阿维·沙洛姆·托尔是一位法学与经济学界的人士。所以他在哈佛的 SJD（法学博士）项目里，这有点像法学博士（JD）的博士版本。无论如何，当我向他描述我的博士论文时，我的意思是，正是阿维·沙洛姆有点说：“哦，好吧，简而言之，你研究的基本上就是竞争心理学。”他提出了这一点。有趣的是，在社会心理学中，对竞争行为和竞争的研究实际上曾经历过一段低谷期。因此，（你知道的）精通新心理学和经济学的阿维·沙洛姆·托尔能够运用那种语言。
And I think that language and also that mutual interest in this kind of work, the study of the psychology of competition, was something that led us to sort of what we think is hopefully help reignite the study of the psychology of competition. Because for years, for decades, it was not really the focus in social psychology. even though social psychology and even Festinger himself when developing social comparison theory was talking specifically about competitive behavior. So that's how this research program grew from that initial conversation way back then. And just to wrap up, what are you working on now? What are the big questions you're trying to answer? So one of the things we're looking at now is we're looking at what are some situational factors
And I think that language and also that mutual interest in this kind of work, the study of the psychology of competition, was something that led us to sort of what we think is hopefully help reignite the study of the psychology of competition. Because for years, for decades, it was not really the focus in social psychology. even though social psychology and even Festinger himself when developing social comparison theory was talking specifically about competitive behavior. So that's how this research program grew from that initial conversation way back then. And just to wrap up, what are you working on now? What are the big questions you're trying to answer? So one of the things we're looking at now is we're looking at what are some situational factors|||我认为这种语言以及对这类工作（即竞争心理学研究）的共同兴趣，促使我们（我们认为是这样）有助于重新点燃对竞争心理学研究的热情。因为多年来，几十年来，这并不是社会心理学的真正焦点。尽管社会心理学，甚至费斯廷格（Festinger）本人在发展社会比较理论时，也专门谈到了竞争行为。这就是这个研究项目如何从当年的那次初步对话中发展而来的。最后，您现在在研究什么？您试图回答的重大问题是什么？所以我们现在正在研究的事情之一是，我们正在研究有哪些情境因素
that can affect one's willingness to tolerate inequality. And so in follow-up work to our N-effect research, which was what we would call where the more competitors, the lower the motivation to compete, we have a recent paper looking at what we're calling inequality, N standing for a number of payoff recipients and inequality. And so what we find is that when people are paying others, they feel more pressure to pay them equally when there are only a few than when there are many.
that can affect one's willingness to tolerate inequality. And so in follow-up work to our N-effect research, which was what we would call where the more competitors, the lower the motivation to compete, we have a recent paper looking at what we're calling inequality, N standing for a number of payoff recipients and inequality. And so what we find is that when people are paying others, they feel more pressure to pay them equally when there are only a few than when there are many.|||会影响一个人容忍不平等意愿。因此，在对我们的“N 效应”研究（即我们所说的竞争对手越多，竞争动机越低的效应）的后续研究中，我们最近发表了一篇论文，研究我们所谓的“不平等 N 效应”，其中 N 代表获得报酬者的数量以及不平等。我们发现，当人们向他人支付报酬时，如果人数较少，与人数较多时相比，他们会感受到更大的压力去进行平均分配。
So for example, let's say if they're having an estate and they're trying to determine how much money they're going to leave their children, if they only have three kids, there's probably going to be more pressure to pay those three children equally than if they had, let's say, well, 30 kids. If you have 30 kids, then it doesn't really matter. I mean, I, you know, maybe. Elon Musk. Right.
So for example, let's say if they're having an estate and they're trying to determine how much money they're going to leave their children, if they only have three kids, there's probably going to be more pressure to pay those three children equally than if they had, let's say, well, 30 kids. If you have 30 kids, then it doesn't really matter. I mean, I, youening know. Elon Musk. Right.|||例如，比方说，如果他们拥有遗产，并试图决定给孩子们留下多少钱，如果他们只有三个孩子，与拥有（比如说）嗯，30 个孩子相比，平等对待这三个孩子的压力可能会更大。如果你有 30 个孩子，那就无所谓了。我的意思是，我，（你知道的）。埃隆·马斯克。没错。
Oh, there you go. Yeah. Yeah. So I mean, three versus 30, that works with our study paradigm. But yeah, but that's kind of the idea. Or if you're at work, if you're part of a larger versus a smaller department, that also can affect the variance in salaries. So we looked at faculty salaries at the University of Texas system.
Oh, there you go. Yeah. Yeah. So I mean, three versus 30, that works with our study paradigm. But yeah, but that's kind of the idea. Or if you're at work, if you're part of a larger versus a smaller department, that also can affect the variance in salaries. So we looked at faculty salaries at the University of Texas system.|||哦，原来如此。是的。是的。所以我的意思是，3 个对 30 个，这符合我们的研究范式。但是，是的，这就是那个意思。或者如果你在工作单位，如果你身处一个较大的部门与较小的部门，这也会影响薪资的差异。因此，我们研究了德克萨斯大学系统的教职员工薪酬。
And we found at the department level, on average, the more faculty members in a department, the higher the variance in pay compared to the smaller the department, the narrower the variance in pay. Now, that real world data is very much confounded, but we, again, just recently published a whole bunch of experiments showing this effect, and that's what we call the inequality effect. Well, Dr. Garcia, I want to thank you for joining me today. This was really interesting and fun. Yeah, thank you very much for the invitation. I'm very grateful. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们发现在系所层面，平均而言，系里教职员越多，薪酬的方差就越大；相比之下，系越小，薪酬的方差就越小。现在，现实世界的数据虽然存在很多混杂因素，但我们最近刚刚发表了一系列实验来展示这种效应，这就是我们所说的“不平等效应”。加西亚博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。这真的非常有趣且愉快。是的，非常感谢您的邀请。我非常感激。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及其他您收听播客的平台上找到《心理学对话》往期的节目。
And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kemp. Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel
如果您喜欢我们节目，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的坎普·基姆·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。在拉尔夫超市（Ralph's），您可以享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有的低价。当您下载拉尔夫超市应用程序时，您每周可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取积分
points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years, savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply by C-Site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
积分可在加油时每加仑节省高达 1 美元。在拉尔夫超市，您每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过优惠和奖励，每天大省一笔总是轻而易举。拉尔夫超市南加州分店已有一百五十多年历史，省钱金额可能因州而异。燃油限制适用，详情请参阅现场说明。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。